while joining me now is community leader
Pastor Lorraine Jonesborough hi it's
good to see you thanks for joining us
how surprised are you at these findings
it's horrific it's extremely painful but
it's been happening for decades okay
my son Dwayne who was killed through
knife crime before he was killed he went
through a number of strip searches and
so did so many other black black young
boys in Lambeth
the the trauma that it's caused
it's so damaging
we don't want it to happen unless it's a
matter of life and death and there are
Pacific offices that can do this in the
right way with an appropriate adult but
it has been happening on a large scale
when I saw these figures I said my God
this is still happening I mean with our
daughter child cue we're a very close
Community the black community that was
like breaking the camel's back but
there's so much more going on it's a
life-changing
experience it's traumatic emotionally
and mentally and this has caused a large
amount of young people and people from
the black community to distrust the
police it shattered the trust because of
what our children are going through
what needs to happen what do you want it
needs it needs to stop it needs to stop
and it it once this has happened it
doesn't stop there
okay when my son died he was on a life
support machine for two days in King's
College Hospital
the first thing I said to my son
was Dwayne the police can't harass you
anymore that's how traumatizing and the
impact they had in Angel town
they were being stopped and so and when
they strip such they would bring him in
the van touch them in inappropriately it
wasn't just my son because I'm a
community leader I'm a pastor I was
speaking to a lot of families and then
of young people and they would tell me
what they went through they would touch
them inappropriately and we're talking
about young black boys
it was embarrassing and traumatizing
some of them couldn't speak to their
parents now if a child is going to be
strip searched by another person it's
child abuse
just because it's the police
how they're doing it doesn't make it any
different these children are left
scarred we don't want it to happen
unless it's a matter of life and death
there has to be an appropriate adult
with them but that is the last resort we
don't want that to happen so you think
there are only very very rare
circumstances when this should be
allowed to happen the police would say
if they do it they may be looking for
concealed weapons or drugs or the like
oh
how many children have they strip
searched and found these items
when this violation happens there's no
apology
there's no therapy and therapy is needed
can you imagine an innocent child being
strip searched by a stranger
yes they're police but there's total
strangers to these children and there's
no aftercare
what do we think is going to happen to
them
we want to know how many cases have they
found these items and if not
I think that these offices need to be
disciplined and the power needs to be
taken away because we know that not all
officers are using their powers in the
right way it's all coming out but these
changes are happening to innocent
children and families that are being
scarred for life you mentioned child cue
you know her I I don't know her
personally but as I said K we're the
black community are very close I see her
as my daughter I don't know how she is
right now I was about to ask how she's
coped I don't know how she's caught but
I know that she obviously it doesn't
just go away it doesn't just go away and
you know the chief counsel needs to see
the impact of such Powers being executed
on these children
it's a devastating impact so it
shouldn't happen and if it does have to
happen they have to be absolutely sure
that what they want to find is there an
appropriate adults is there an Aftercare
is given and if they're carrying these
things out and they're not finding
anything there needs to be some kind of
discipline
um and a thought um just before I let
you go Pastor um about your boy it's not
the natural order of things for your
child to die before you how are you
coping
okay
if I didn't have
the grace of God
to be able to advocate for our young
people I've got a boxing gym which he
left I've got a community center
I'm working with some very supportive
police officers and a local Council
to serve our youth if I didn't have that
I probably wouldn't come out my house
I'll probably be on antidepressants and
just withering away I've got seven I've
got seven children so six other children
and four grandchildren but please
if you could see my heart I've got a
broken heart but it's the need of our
youth
Dwayne said to me Mom the youth need
help
this was nine years ago
and every time I feel like giving up I
hear his voice and I see what's going on
and I said I've got to do all that I can
to help them and I'm just so thankful
okay that you're giving us this voice
okay well thank you for taking the time
to join us and do come and see us
whenever you want to thank you thank you
very much indeed thanks a lot